hey leute und willkommen zum einen top 5
texture pack die ich so mittlerweile am
besten finde bzw
die top 5 die ich seit monaten schon am
besten finde ich hab das nun längere
zeit beobachtet was die user so meinten
was ihre lieblings texture pack sind und
das war schneidet sich doch da ein wenig
schon
deswegen wollte ich euch erstmal meine
fünf lieblings text apex vorstellen und
was ihr mir bitte in die kommentare
schreiben solltet wäre ob ich eine serie
machen soll die ich minecraft texture
pack vorstellungen
ne ne also ich stelle euch jetzt hier
die fünf besten texte packs for dich
erstmal so finde aber soll ich noch eine
serie machen wo ich euch immer mal so
ein paar texte packs vorstelle die ihr
vielleicht noch nicht kennt die ich
einfach so ein bisschen zeit also
schreibt er dass auf jeden fall in die
kommentare
und ich will einfach nur freunde dann
würde ich sagen fangen wir mit dem video
und zwar auf platz fünf ist für mich
dass herr sommer texture pack ihr seht
das hier ist noch ein bisschen komisch
weil ich gerade im creative mode bin
aber wenn ihr das seht das hier sind so
die einstellungen also diese ganzen
interface dinge die hier die es hier so
gibt ich habe wählen das gras und
übrigens von gameware shader drin also
das wasser bewegt sich jetzt bei mir
noch nicht weil ich den ball nicht drin
hab aber tiere und so als beleuchtet und
von daher fehlt dass der als ein
bisschen sieht ein bisschen heller aus
ich finde die villiger ganz interessant
und zwar sehen die echt witzig aus
bleibt man stehen hier diese internet
interessant auch ausfindig mit den augen
bisschen so wie keine ahnung so stellt
man sich vielleicht aliens vor ich weiß
es nicht
außerdem sehr geil finde ich allgemein
das holz und die planken daraus gemacht
werden also planken also diese teile
hier die finde ich cool und warum ich
das eigentlich ganz cool finde
eigentlich mag ich ja märklin ist ludwig
attacks cap ex aber ich finde wenn man
irgendwie so wälder sieht oder solche
tannenwälder oder berge oder so das
passt einfach extrem ihr rein wenn man
denkt wirklich so man streicht man
streift jetzt durch eine landschaft
durch ist ein bisschen doku kraft
ähnlich also ein bisschen rollenspiel
lastig moment das sieht man hier ist so
eine kleine genau da sieht man das ganz
gut
übrigens die map steht in der
beschreibung wenn ihr euch die in
litauen laden wollte das ist jetzt die
elvia welt denke ich also glaube ich
weiß ich also auf platz 5 von mir
gewählte doktor sommer und
na ja ich würde sagen wir gehen zu platz
vier über platz vier ist für mich
nämlich john smith das habe ich hier das
sieht so ähnlich aus wie das hier moment
die welt muss ich ein bisschen aufbauen
dass dort ein bisschen bevor hier sofort
alles ich mir hier so gezielt diesen
diese blätter an das ist ja sexy sexy
sexy so wir laufen wieder zurück zu dem
village kurz es ist alles ein bisschen
trist gehalten aber eigentlich schon der
gleiche grund wie bei wie heißt es noch
mal lieber herr sommer ich finde das
ganze sogar das ist alles ein bisschen
rollenspiel mäßig aussieht ist ein
bisschen mittelalter mittelalterlich
auch bilder sehen da extrem geil das
natürlich wenn wir jetzt moderne sachen
bord es geht mit diesem diesen texture
pack glaube ich nicht so gut aber wir
hier unten seht wenn da in die wälder
sind oder ähnliches das kann man schon
anbieten mit diesem text speck ich werde
hier mal kurz runter gehen weil hier
noch ein paar sachen sind in der map die
echt geil aussehen zum beispiel wenn man
sich hierhin stellten sich das angucken
sich doch mal ewig aus naja also platz
vier für mich john smit dann will ich
sagen kommt auch sofort weiter zu platz
drei platz drei ist nämlich für mich
dass meine cross meiner kraft royal von
der lieth moneyball das sieht hier mit
dem shaker alles ein bisschen komisch
aus der shader an sich ich finde ihn
jetzt nicht allzu toll aber eigentlich
wenn ihr warum sind nie so komische
farbstellungen naja egal das ist halt
dieser komische shader aber wir schon
sieht was hier in diesem text speck ganz
cool finde ist das alles wirklich über
alles drauf geachtet es ein paar insider
drin von community und als coolster
finde ich eigentlich ist wenn man damit
irgendwie in den berg reingeht und in
höhlen und so das sieht alles extrem
genial aus nur mit diesem schiller sieht
das jetzt ein bisschen crazy alles aus
also ich weiß nicht woran das liegt aber
sich halt alles ein bisschen komisch
aussieht seht das gras es jetzt
irgendwie grün jetzt ist es wieder
leader
sieht ein bisschen komisch aus aber naja
auf platz drei für mich meine kraft
downloaded es einfach und dann werdet
ihr schon sehen dass euch das gefällt
denke ich mal hoffe ich mal also ich
finde auf jeden fall gut
dann will ich sagen kommt auch sofort
weiter zu platz zwei das ist nämlich für
mich zwecks pio bi die craft 64er
version ja hier mit sich jetzt wieder
normal das ist interessant also ich
finde das ist einfach so ein text gepäck
das ist wirklich so comic mäßig wenn ich
irgendwie abbauen will oder in erhöhen
oder die ganze zeit irgendwas abbauen
will oder so dann kann ich dieses tags
speck nur empfehlen weil man damit
wirklich
man hat halt also bei mir ist es so ich
hab da so richtig bock dann irgendwie
steine abzubauen oder irgendwie sowas
weil ich finde das einfach so genial
dieses texture pack das ist alles so
comic mäßig ist das ist schon cool vor
allem im schneidersitz doch eigentlich
ganz gut aus vielleicht werd ich das mal
so im display verwenden weiß ich noch
nicht
jetzt sind wir wieder beim village und
es ist halt wirklich alles kommt mäßig
gehalten haben jetzt besten sieht man
dass hier bei der erde einfach finde ich
auf jeden fall genial dieses texture
pack finde ich sehr witzig vor allem die
typen hier scharf ist auch ganz niedlich
finde ich richtig richtig hammer dieses
action pack auf jeden fall runterladen
ich weiß dass pete smith benutzers auch
und viel mehr eigentlich auf mich also
glaube ich radu kleiner ofen es kaputt
gemacht finde ich auf jeden fall sehr
geil das texture pack kommen wir zu
platz eins platz eins ist für mich ein
text etwas noch nicht so lange bzw noch
nicht so bekannt ist und zwar ist das
janina kraft aber es liegt mit shader
aber auch ohne schilder einfach extrem
geil aus und ich finde es ist eine
mischung aus allem
denn es ist ein bisschen mutig das was
ich mag es in texturen von nisa darin
von meine kraft und eigene kreationen
ich finde es ist wirklich wo es mich
einfach weil ich mein wenn ihr euch die
blöcke anguckt das ist echt einfach zum
beispiel auch beim stein oder so man
sieht echt dass das einfach so klien
locker leicht keine ahnung finde ich
halt richtig geil das texture pack
benutze ich auch an den let's play paar
zimmer
und ich find's auf jeden fall hammer und
ja also er fünfter platz herr sommer
theaterplatz john smith dritter platz
meine kraft royal zweiter platz 6 ppg
kreft und erster platz janina kraft dann
würde ich sagen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat gibt ihn bitte einen daumen
hoch schreibt in die kommentare ob ich
solle tech speck vorstellung vielleicht
noch mal machen soll
von anderen texture pack ist halt eure
entscheidung ob ihr das wollt und dann
würde ich ganz einfach auch sagen wir
sehen uns im nächsten video schönen tag
noch und schaue ich hab mir grad mit
pizza gemacht ich glaube dies jetzt
angebrannt welchem der total lang
aufgenommen
bis zum nächsten mal